hi i'm simon Sinek and this is adrian
zach i'm and we are the co publishers of
a new imprint at penguin Random House
called optimism press adrian has been a
publisher at penguin Random House for
how many years 17 years 17 years longer
than I've been alive I've been an author
with penguin Random House for more than
a decade now so this is something that
has been a long time in the making where
we decided to start something new
together so we called this imprint that
we've started optimism press what is the
reason that you wanted to call it
optimism press well since this is a
mission that you wanted to take
undertake in the beginning and since
optimism since you identify yourself as
an optimist an optimism is clearly part
of your mission and everything you do it
just seemed like the natural jumping-off
point for anything we were gonna do
together that had that really was under
your brand so it it wasn't a difficult
question for me and I don't think it was
for you either no no I think it's a
perfect shelf you know you know the the
the the optimism is a perfect shelf for
which all ideas that either either mine
or ones that I fall in love with should
sit on they should be first and foremost
forward forward facing and and have have
a confidence that that the future is
bright yes and I think all of our all of
our the ideas that we hope to share with
the world will pay off the promise of
optimism what is your vision for
optimism pressed I imagine a world that
does not yet exist I imagine a world in
which the vast majority of people wake
up every single morning inspired feel
safe at work and return home fulfilled
at the end of the day I've completely
devoted my life and career to trying to
build this world and one of the nice
things about my journey is that I have
the opportunity to meet some wonderful
people who are contributing to building
that world they're running organizations
they're inside organizations there are
leaders there
there are all sorts of people and some
of them have ideas that I believe are so
significant that the rest of us need to
know those ideas and so for me it was so
exciting to to have the opportunity to
form my own imprint with penguin Random
House that we have an opportunity to
introduce the rest of the world to the
people and the ideas that I think are
essential pieces of the jigsaw puzzle to
help build that vision and what gave you
the idea to work with penguin Random
House in the first place well you and I
you've been my publisher for all my
books and you and I have known each
other for over 10 years in over a decade
and I think it's safe to say that we do
good work together you know I could not
have written any of my books without you
and it's it's become more than a
business relationship it's a true
friendship and a true collaboration and
I trust you immensely and I trust your
judgement and you are extremely good at
taking good ideas and making them into
great ideas and so when when I had this
idea to form the imprint there's quite
frankly no one else I'd rather partner
with to help do it because we will find
good ideas and we'll make them into
great books and in fact there were books
before the imprint that we collaborated
on not your books but other writers
meant many of which were quite
successful and we had fun doing it it's
true it's true we I've it's true we have
helped we have done things together
under different imprints and it worked
out well so it was a good we had
presidents this is this was low risk for
you and me as we know it doing so we
could work that was the reason you
wanted to do an imprint with me well it
goes back to the same question we had
worked together on books that you had
found in your travels and several of
them had worked out really well and it
introduced me to some fantastic writers
and thinkers and so when you said why
don't we formulate a strategy together
and do this in a sort of planned way
instead of just by acts by lucky
accident I jumped at the opportunity it
seemed like like a fantastic chance to
produce to do some great publishing I
think one of the things that people
don't realize about our friendship is
that a lot of the risks that we take
aren't actually risks for us I think you
and I see a lot of things we do as
no-brainers you know we have common
cause
we and we know how to work together and
I think other people when we say we're
gonna do this people go but we go no no
it'll be fine and we met it it's worked
out okay knock on wood yeah yeah that's
fine
Simon what what do you hope to achieve
with the new imprint I know that my
ideas are a piece of a bigger jigsaw
puzzle my own books it this this this
big vision that I have I I have a couple
of the pieces and so what I'm hoping is
that these books as we build them over
the course of time offer a road a path a
a compass direction and and and on how
we actually build this this world that's
different from now the goal is to give
not only to share the ideas and and that
we that we stumble upon that we think of
valuable but also to give bigger
platforms to our authors I hope that
they all have bigger and more successful
careers as as speakers for this movement
for their own ideas so I'm really hoping
to give them a bigger louder platform
because certainly all the authors we've
signed up so far we've fallen in love
with them and their ideas and we want we
want others to fall in love with them
and their ideas to tell us about some of
the authors that we've already signed up
with for the list so the book that we
are launching with is by summer rain
Oaks it's a book called how to make a
plant love you I met summer many many
years ago we've been close friends for
awhile and she has she's just a
powerhouse and an optimist and a
wonderful human being and she has this
fantastic idea about how to raise plants
how to look after plants her she who's
been featured in the press multiple
times because she has I don't remember
one hundred six hundred plants in her
New York City apartment in her Brooklyn
apartment and I've been I think it's up
to seven was up to seven and it's an
amazing place to visit you know you sort
of move the vines out of the way to wash
the dishes you know it's really
fantastic
and she these plants grow and thrive
inside her New York City apartment and
it's because it's not by luck it's
because she understands the plants and
she understands where to put them and
how to nurture them
and so we the way we treat plants is we
see a plant that we think is pretty and
we think ooh it would look nice over
there in that coffee table and we buy
the plant we put on the coffee table and
the plant dies it's because we bought
the plant that we wanted and put it
where we wanted it and the reality is
you have to know where the plant wants
to be not where we want to put it and
you have to put it in the place where
it's more likely to thrive what I love
about summers work is it's a metaphor
because we do that with people we take
somebody and we put them in the job that
we want them to do and then we get
frustrated that they don't succeed and
so we move them and they don't succeed
again but we never actually think to ask
where would they naturally thrive what
environment what position what job
should we put that person and so that
they'll do well though yes and on one
level summers book is actually a
wonderful book for people who want to
know more about how to look after plants
but there's really a very important and
deep-seated message contained within
this book about how to treat people
mm-hmm it's a really it's a big metaphor
that if you learn how to take care of
plants how to make a plant love you
we're actually learning how to make
people love you how to make people fall
in love with their jobs and each other
it's just it's just a wonderful and it's
so full of depth and she's such a
talented writer I I couldn't think of a
better book that I'd rather I'd rather
introduce the world to our imprint with
we're also publishing a book by Bruce
deal called trust first as you know
Bruce runs an organization called City
of Refuge in Atlanta Georgia and he I
don't know how to put it he saves people
to put it mildly drug addicts and
hookers and all these people and he
takes on the street and he gives them a
second chance and he believes in them
and when you and I met Bruce I think we
were the whole room and this was
enamored with him because Bruce does
something that I think few of us have
the courage to do which he he gives
people extreme trust he takes somebody
who the rest of society would say is
unworthy of our trust and he trusts them
as if they were old friends or family
and what he has learned is that when you
take the risk to trust people they rise
to the occasion and they they're able to
transform their lives they're able to
transform their path
and to one that is more positive for
them and those around them and though it
is a remarkable story about trust and
what Bruce is doing I the the it's an
extreme version of the lesson I think we
could all learn I think few people and I
don't think we would ever recommend for
anybody to trust the way Bruce trusts I
think that that's a whole or another
order of trust but if we could learn to
trust better than we do now to take the
risk to trust people more than we do to
learn from Bruce's example I think it
makes for better organizations and it
makes for better collaboration you know
better work environments better cultures
better society better finish ups talk
about inspiring when I brought Bruce and
summer to your attention
what's the reason that you also said but
we have to do these books well you know
I examined our earliest conversations
about this program which was to give to
seize an opportunity to identify voices
that were inspiring in some way that
inspired us to to operate on a higher
level in the case of summer yes as you
said it's about plants but it's really
about living life at a higher level and
an enhancing life so that was an easy
one and then Bruce not only does he
trust people but in his case he put
himself and his family and not
inconsiderable risk from for many years
and became a living example of how Trust
transforms individuals families
communities and in the case of his
hometown Atlanta whole cities and he has
been a tremendous change agent so on
every level that book and and and he
himself personally his is a source of
huge inspiration and I think will change
lives I tell you what I'm excited about
his imprint which a pattern is starting
to form in the books that were
publishing and planning to publish
though many books are about the idea
that the book is about
mmm clearly you buy a book and myths
about that whatever it says on the cover
it's about that I mean that's what most
books are about what I'm starting to see
in our in our
books is our books operate on multiple
levels there's there's the idea set that
you'll read in the pages and then
there's an underlying idea as well
there's I think all of our books seem to
operate in have to at least a duality at
least at least to do it now yeah and in
which case I think you know when we when
we first said we're gonna do a book
about how to make a plant love you
people scratch their there are eyebrows
raise your writing you said you
publishing a book about what you know
and here we are saying that the imprint
exists to inspire a different kind of
world and this is this is this is our
first book but I think I think that's
correct I think a lot of our books will
will be unsuspecting too when we
announce what they are but but they fit
our strategy and and and they're there I
think a lot of them will be metaphors
frankly and and have those those dual
messages I am really yeah it's excited
last question how do you hope that
optimism press will change the way
people think about business in life the
one of the things that I think all of
the work that I'm interested in does is
it challenges people's perspective of
how they think the world works and it
forces people to examine their own
preconceptions and some of the things
that we are even told are just the way
the world works and I'm hoping that in
total all of our work in some way shape
or form challenges at first and then
changes people's view of how the world
works but also what is possible I think
we if we read all those books I think we
will all be changed we all be slightly
different because of it you know
everybody used to believe the world was
flat at one point until it wasn't
and I'm hoping that this this library
that will produce will have a similar
effect that many preconceived notions of
how to treat people or how the world
works or how businesses work or how
organizations work well will be
different 10 or 50
from now in part because of because of
these books I hope so I hope so too yeah
and then when I done it fried again did
you say
so Simon wait I'm not done you're not
done laughing it's hard for us to do
serious huh we don't do serious no okay
so Simon what is your vision for
optimism for us